hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob wolf and
this is family tussle the father-son
competition show where the loser has to
do an embarrassing punishment
let go well today we are doing it's a
model competition uh Rock Film clothes
will be put in front of us and we will
get to choose two outfits if we're going
to be judged on our style
and our catwalk he's gonna try and win
based on Comedy or style points raw sex
I'm I'm bubbling with testosterone
probably not at my age you know that
little swish walk where that leg comes
in front of the other
where you have to be careful not to
squish your nuts together strategy going
into the competition flipping the hair a
lot of hips in the walk you know just
some stuff I've picked up some from a
Victoria Secret fashion show I've seen
Zoolander like 40 times
get ready to kiss my heels baby
because this walk is going to be fierce
so we're in the dressing room today is
the model competition part of the thing
we're being judged on is our style
so we have to pick our own clothes
luckily our stylist Nicole is here so
she'll be able to give us suggestions
and she's not going to say what's good
and bad she can't do that
but wait we'll be able to read that
poker face
yeah okay all right
it's gonna go straight none real quick
hey I can hear you oh yeah that's true I
forgot I forgot like this isn't like the
magic of TV like he's literally yeah
why can you look over that you tall
what I'm worried about this is It's So
high-waisted I think I'm gonna have a
friend on either side
a great idea
all right that's a nun
nuns don't usually have dicks like that
but that's interesting it's not that bad
oh
you're gonna hold it like that okay hold
it like that no you hold it like that I
hold it like that no when you walk you
gotta cross it over you gotta have a
little hat
I feel like I've got my outfit I think I
got mine I think I'm ready each one of
us gets to choose a look for this
competition so I thought I'd choose one
then he knows nothing about First Look
70s swinger party foreign
[Music]
foreign
you know a lot of people used to call my
dad Mr Mom growing up I'm not sure why
but that's why I chose this look and
this look is 80s mom foreign
[Music]
foreign
you know they had me at nipples that's
all I have to say
um I was hard for me to concentrate
after that lopsided breasts did you
notice that I think it gave it character
okay you know well that's real titties
though that's what I'm saying do you
have an idea for your final score do you
think you know I think so I think I'm
ready Josh yes three socks in your left
tit and two socks and your right tip
listen 80s mom she's had a couple babies
one of the boobies is milk a lot and
it's just it's not his part it's it's
good that you brought up the babies
because I have a question sure where
is the baby well I'm an 80s Mom I don't
pay attention to my kids I just do a ton
of coats
I don't know why but that was the right
answer would you care to elaborate on
your makeup Choice Jacob yeah I was just
going for a little bit of a flare um I
know it's not very 80s mom but I was
just going for something a little bit
different yeah you landed somewhere
around like Marilyn Manson keyboard
player now do you think you're setting a
bad example for young Jacob here with
that cigarette uh we're way past that I
think we're ready to make our decision
okay
final score
for Jacob
[Applause]
[Music]
all right final score for Josh
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm talking about you know what I'm
saying hey would you feel pretty good
about this yeah I feel pretty good thank
you judges Jacob let me just say this
dude for real you wear clothes like so
like when you put this in all honesty
that doesn't look too terrible on you
but when we started model competition
the reason I was nervous is because you
look like a model and you had you have a
good walk so I knew I had to accessorize
and so but you you nailed it yeah I went
technical again trying to trying to do
it like I did in the last couple ones
that took technical over style but uh I
think
buddy I love you too
I don't know if I want to hug you yeah
come on in It's Gonna feel good
be ready no
come join a great community
hi ladies ask me on tips on how to live
life with herpes it's not that bad how
you doing sir ask if you want to ask any
tips on how to live life with herpes it
hasn't been a problem well that's good
I'm glad I'm here you know syphilis is
way worse anyways Melissa you guys want
to ask me tips on how to live life with
herpes at all
no all right cool it's not that bad
you're missing out you're missing out on
a great Community all right
[Music]
I don't know in case in case it does
happen any point in the future I do I'm
out here just trying to embrace
everybody and make everybody feel better
I think well for me I have to tell them
before because for me it's a common
courtesy to make sure pathetically if he
has herpes
[Applause]
[Music]
I gotta say probably protected sex but
anything else all right my friend thank
you so much have a great day now all
right that was so good do I keep going
[Music]